a frico camp and welcome to another the
daily program or webseries video and in
this one we're going to talk about
problem number three 1/5 X or
multiplication which is posted on the
daily program or subreddit and then
before we dive into this problem
remember to brush up on your bitwise
operations because we're going to be
using them in a solution come time to
implement in JavaScript all right so
let's break it down the whiteboard so
for this XOR multiplication example they
give you two inputs right they give you
an input a in this case is the integer
14 and then they give you input B which
is another integer in this case it's 13
and then the base two equivalents of
these two integers would be 1 1 1 0 4 14
and 1 1 0 1 4 13
so given this information their whole
XOR multiplication is defined like so
for every bit an input B or in this case
the bottom number 13 we need to write
out input a if the bit is 1 so in this
case the first bit on the right is a 1
so we're going to go ahead and write out
input a and then we've taken care of
that bit so we can cross it up and then
for the next part of the multiplication
you just go ahead and indent 1 so I'll
go ahead an indent 1 here and then if
it's a 0 for this bit on the far right
that you've moved in 1 on we just go
ahead and write a 0 here and then repeat
the process where you indent one more
time and in this case we're at a 1 so we
need to rewrite this 14 out so I can say
0 1 1 1 and again if it is a very last
bit we need to end it a third time and
write out 0 1 1 1 and now at this point
you can just do an XOR operation on all
the ones beforehand so in this case if
you XOR 1 1 1 0 1 0 you get 1 1 1 0 so I
can go ahead and write that out here and
you get X or this line with this line
you're going to go ahead and get 1 1
zero one one zero and I'll ask you the X
for this line with this line you're
going to go ahead and get one zero zero
zero one one zero which will actually
convert to the integer of seventy so
just to make sure that was kind of odd
because I still can walk through it one
last time so I'll go ahead erase this
and I'll rewrite this bottom string so
remember the algorithm that they're
presenting to you is that for every bit
in 13 starting from the right you need
to write out the top one if it's a 1 and
then indent for every bit so let's do
this one by one so again we'll cross
that the one will write out and put a
which is 14 so then we get to the next
bit zero and then we have to indent one
so let's go ahead and set a to zero here
and then we can XOR these which leaves
us with one one one zero we can cross
out this bit which leaves us two
indentations and because the first one
this is the second one and then write
out input eggs
X where those together and we get one
one zero one one zero and it's finally
we cross that this [ __ ] we end in three
right out input a and then XOR them all
together
which again leaves us with one zero zero
zero one one zero which equates to 70 so
again for this problem they basically
broke down the algorithm that we need to
implement and the only thing we need to
do is just let galva script and
implement it so let's go ahead and do
that now okay so to start off let's go
ahead and make a function called X or
multiply we're going to take two
parameters and be like we discussed on
the whiteboard and down here let's just
go ahead and call it with 14 and 13 the
same values that we did on the board and
then we can just go ahead and return
null here so the first thing I'm gonna
do is I'm going to declare a results
variable where we can keep track of the
results when we keep X soaring a to a
shifted to a shifted etc and then I
could just say return results down here
so that function should make sense and
the first thing that we mentioned in the
white board is that we want to keep
looping over B until we run out of bits
or run out of those you know digits 1 to
0 so we can say while B is not equal to
0 we can just go ahead and keep shifting
off bits so if you know anything about
bitwise operations when you do this
operation we're pretty much saying take
the integer B take its base to
representation and shift a bit off to
the right so if it was 1 1 0 1 it will
now become 1 1 0 and then 1 1 and then 1
and we can actually show this if I also
go ahead and say console.log beat out 2
string base 2 and C console is not
defined so it prints out again the first
iteration the first thing and loop is
going to print out 1 1 0 1 and then it
prints out 1 1 0 and then it prints out
1 1 1 and then 1 so it's going to be
four times and then one time for every
character right until we reach 0 so
hopefully this part makes sense and then
again to demonstrate the other part you
know step two of that algorithm is every
time you do an iteration you need to
shift a over to the left one so you need
to add a zero to a and what we can do is
the opposite we can say a
less than less than equal one which is
again a bitwise operation which will
push the integer a of the base to
representation over one so again I can
say console.log a two strings a base two
and we see each iteration it adds a zero
to the end so now for the last part
remember all we do all we have to do is
just take a result and keep X oaring it
with a if the bit of B on the far right
is equal to one so I can say result X or
equals a which won't necessarily give us
which our site results so that won't
give us the answer that we're looking
for because we need to only X or when
the rightmost right bit of B is equal to
1 so we can times it by B and then check
if the right bit is on and we get our
final answer of 70 down here I was going
to print out this two string so again we
can kind of walk through this and get a
better understanding what's going on so
the first iteration B is 1 1 0 1 and a
is 1 1 1 0 and then we need 2 times 1 1
1 0 by the first bit and B and it's 1 in
this case the result it becomes 1 1 1 0
and then the way we're going to shift
over a shift over B the loop goes on one
more where B is equal to 1 1 0 a now has
an extra 0 at the end and again we check
if the most far-right bit is on for B
and if it is we just XOR results with a
again which leaves us with the exact
same results down here so you see that
results for the first iteration is 1 1 1
0 second iteration is also 1 1 1 0 and
then for the third iteration B is equal
to 1 1 the most right bits on so
therefore we XOR results with 1 1 1 0
which is a
and we're left with this and then we
again repeat it for the last one again
be sure to LIKE the video we thought it
was good and be sure to subscribe to
frito camp below alright thanks for
watching